who's a player or two that stood out to
you so far today John or it's summer
like who's a guy we look at you say okay
you know what I can see where this piece
might fit it had some rumors from my
inside people there that something could
be coming but I who knows we go on a
three or four-day game winning streak we
just can't play you guys that's been
really bad no I want to ask you guys
this coach Chantry when you're watching
the summer league games what are some of
the things you're looking for
specifically that you need to see across
the board in guys when you're out here
watching that you can see that most
important to him as his family his mom
is the best coach he had because she's
been the toughest coach for the a fault
a player leaping in school to play for
his dad as a head coach or I don't
Jackson hey shows nice touch no you
can't and it wasn't an accident led for
three quarters of the game did you do
that game didn't call that game with
Doris Burke I'm not gonna lie to you I
watched that game while I was playing
blackjack that trade going to Oklahoma
City now Alexander with a nice scoop
shot got the bucket the ball come on
Chicago Little League again - he is
gonna be good going on a nice baseline
oh wow
Jackson Hayes hit the delete button
Kansas City Chiefs big time tight in
watch this come sprint yeah Jonathan
played let's say he had the longest
wingspan ever at the combine long inside
blocked
[Applause]
highly recruited anybody the country he
really was in Mississippi State got him
it was fine but then had a nice nice run
at Kansas and we were talking about some
of the assets particularly Brandon
Ingram and he just raved about Brandon
Ingram back then it in February not
something that was more pathological so
then I'm not a doctor I don't even play
one on TV but it just sounds like he's
gonna be ok moving Bulls with anything
had it once in college it did not end
well Dennis Smith jr. the New York
Knicks watching courtside Hayes Flushing
at home will see the New York Knicks
it's one thing in the middle of December
but when you make him in the fight whoa
with the side spin three hit the global
spin soon he had to do that
Brad Stevens really excited about it
walk her inside tough shot
boy he might be the player of the game
which that has a lot of tentacles and
branches to his coaching trees man I
tell you about Fred Vincent's the coach
of me
hit me meanwhile Jackson Hayes belacan
he came into the game one of the top
scorers in summer league averaging 28